ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคน
[เพลง]
ผู้หญิงคะคะคลิปนี้คลิปสุดท้าย
2high อ่ะอะ
กินหน้าศูนย์สุดท้ายตอนโอเคอันนี้
ของอะไรคะวันอาทิตย์ค่ะครูเอ๋เอ๋มัน
อาทิตย์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
ถ้า 16  17 วันที่ 17 ค่ะ
ผู้หญิงร้องไห้รถลืมเลยเหรอลืมวันเดือนมี
อะไรเดือน
เมษายนค่ะปีพตเท่าไหร่คะดีพ.ต.ต.
ปีคศเท่าไหร่คะ
2022 ค่ะ
2022 ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงตอนนี้เวลา
06:32
นาที
06:32 นาทีนะคะใช่ค่ะ
ผู้หญิงค่ะบ๊ายบายวันนี้ก็เป็นคลิป L  40
ๆคลิปที่
40 ของคอร์สเนาะครูเอ๋เนี่ยมีคำถามใช่
ไหมคะพี่เอ๋ไม่ถ้าไม่รีบที่ 1 คลิปที่ 2
คลิกที่ 3 ครูเอ๋มีคำถามถ้ามีนักเรียน
แล้วก็คลิปที่ 4  5  6  7  8  9  10 ครู
หญิงมีคำถาม
มาถามนะเรียนเรามีนักเรียนตอนนี้เนาะ
เรามีนักเรียนเนี่ย
11 คอนน์วรรณา 11 คนเราเนี่ยรู้จักนัก
เรียนแล้วค่ะอ๋อใช่ๆรู้จักนิดหน่อยนะ
เรียนชื่ออะไร
เอกจำได้นิดหน่อยๆกับชื่อแบรด์ที่
โรเบิร์ต
พี่ไม่ชอบดู Twilight ใช่ไหมคะคุณโร
เบิร์ตแพททินสันนะคะคุณ Black  it นะคะ
เอ่อ
ครูเอ๋รู้นะเรียนคุณลิซ่าคุณแคะคุณเค้า
คุณ John  and  khun  John คุณแตฮีคุณโอ
คุณ
อาจ
ธนทัต
ยิ้ม 5 อย่าลืมใครอ่ะคุณจะได้ๆแล้วมั้ย 11
คนยังคุณแรส Robert คุณ John คุณ John
คุณทาดาชิกุญแจคุณเคล้าขาวขอโทษค่ะ
เค้าครูเอ๋จำรู้จักชื่อนักเรียนรู้จักนัก
เรียนมาจากประเทศอะไร
ใช่ไหมบุญทาดาชิออกมาจากประเภทอะไรหา
ผู้หญิงถามกูอีกใช่ไหมตอนนี้ยังยังไม่ถาม
อ่ะ
สุดท้ายราชิรู้
ฝันชื่อใช่ไหมฝันชื่อรู้คุณทาดาชิมาจาก
ประเทศญี่ปุ่น
100 ครูเอรู้จักนักเรียนมาจากประเทศอะไร
ให้ค่ะ
รู้ว่านักเรียนอ่าทำอาชีพอะไร
หรือและ
อาชีพคุปต์ผู้หญิงฮะๆนาน 30 กว่าคลิปครู
เห็นลืม
ทำได้ประเทศอะไร
อื้อโอเค
ประเทศโอเค
อาชีพอ่ะมีวิวอันนี้ไม่มีนะคะ
ใครภาชีหรอตั้งเครื่องหรอ
จิตรกร
ก่อนคุณทาดาชิทำอาชีพอะไรครูเอ๋จำได้ไหม
จำไม่ได้
คุณทาดาชิเนี่ยเป็นหมอ
ใช่ไหมซ้ายเป็นหมอ
ขอบคุณค่ะ
ต้องกลับไปดูคลิปเก่านะรู้จักวันนี้ทำให้
q-test กูอ่ะคะใช่ค่ะวันนี้เนี่ยครูหญิง
จะเช็คว่าครูเอ๋เนี่ยรู้จักเรียนแล้วจำ
ได้ไหมจำ
จำไม่ได้ไม่เป็นไรไม่เป็นไรครูเอ๋มีสวยๆ
ก็มีค่ะครูหญิงมีคำถามถามครูเอ๋แต่ครูเอ๋
เนี่ยไม่ต้องคิดมากๆมี Choice
ผู้หญิงถามว่าตัด
example นะคะ
คุณทาดาชิมาจากประเทศญี่ปุ่น
ทุกข์
หรือผิดถึงฐานอาทิอันดับประเทศญี่ปุ่นถูก
ค่ะ
น้องเอ๋บอกว่าถูกอะไร
ถ้าถูกโอเคเหมือนมั้ย
เหมือนไหมคะถูก
ถูกถูก
ใช่ค่ะผูกค่ะแม่
ครูเอ๋มันมีแค่ถูกกับผิดออก
อ่าโอเค
โอเคไหมคะครูเองไหมใจสบายใจไม่ยากค่ะข้อ
ที่ 1 ค่ะ
ครูหญิงสถามเกี่ยวกับคุณแบรดพิตต์ถึงแบบ
กินแอ๊ผิด
คนอเมริกา
คุณแร้งอย่าเพิ่งซีคุณก็ถาม
ใจเย็นๆไม่ได้ถามประเทศอ่ะถามประเทศนี่
รัก
คุณแรนพิษมาจากประเทศอเมริกา
ถูกหรือผิดคะครูเอ๋ถูกค่ะ
เร็วว่าถูก
ทุกๆมีชั่วหรอ Bag พิษอเมริกา
อเมริกาเนี่ยถูกค่ะถ้าคุณแบรดพิตต์ Bar
จากอเมริกา
มาจาก
เท็กซัส
ถูกหรือผิดเท็กซัสหรอคุณแบรดพิตต์ผิดคือ
ผิด
ใช่ค่ะอันครับผิดคุณแพ้พิษมาจากที่ไหนใน
อเมริกา
แคลิฟอร์เนียไหม
กูข้าว
เก่งมากจริงปะดีข้อหนึ่งนะกูเห็นมีคน
หนึ่งคะอันนี้เขา 1  1 ไงคุณแรกพิษผู้
หญิงเนี่ยมี 11 ข้อนักเรียน 11 คนโอเคค่ะ
คุณและทิศหมดแล้วบ๊ายบายขอให้นะคะคุณแพ้
พิษอ่ะคนที่ 2 คุณโรเบิร์ตแพททินสัน
อ่ะคุณโรเบิร์ตแพททินสันเนี่ยมาจากประเทศ
อะไรคะครูเอ๋มาจากประเทศอังกฤษจำหนังๆ
คุณโรเบิร์ตมาจากประเทศอังกฤษแล้วก็มาจาก
อยู่อยู่ที่เมืองลอนดอน
ถูกมั้ยถูกหรือผิดคะครูเอ๋โรเบิร์ตแพททิน
สันลอนดอนเลยหรอ Robert แบบมีบ้านมี
อพาร์ทเม้นท์อยู่ที่ลอนดอน
อา
จำได้คิดคิดว่าผิดค่ะ
ผิดอื้อ
มีแต่จำไม่ได้ใช่ไหมคุณโรเบิร์ตมาจาก
เมืองฟุตบอลเมืองฟุตบอลน่ะ
ดีแล้ว
ลิเวอร์พูลลิเวอร์พูลมาจากเมืองเรียกว่า
ภูเบศจำแต่ฟุตบอล
ลิเวอร์พูลฟุตบอลเก่ง
เก่งมากค่ะครูเอ๋ขอบคุณค่ะมีถามเกี่ยวกับ
คุณโรเบิร์ตอีกนะครับไม่มีคุณโรเบิร์ต
เกิดวันเกิด
เกิดเดือนเดือนเดือน
เรือน
สภาคมคุณโรเบิร์ตเกิด
เกิดเดือนพฤษภาคม
งูหรือผิดถูกค่ะ
โทรค่าเธอ
เก่งมากขอครูเอ๋นะคะคุณโรเบิร์ตความจำดี
อะหมดแล้วค่ะคุณโรเบิร์ตแล้วนะคะงั้นพอดี
3 เนี่ยคำถามเกี่ยวกับคุณลิซ่าสวัสดีค่ะ
คุณลิซ่าหน้าคุณลิซ่าเนี่ยนะคะเป็น
พยาบาลมาคุย Lisa เป็นพยาบาลค่ะ
ครูกุ๊กหรือผิดคะครูเอ๋
า
คิดว่าผิดค่ะหวยบอกว่าผิด
ใช่
พิษจากครูอ่ะผิดฉัน
พยาบาลหรอเฮ้ยคุณลิซ่าเป็นพยาบาล
เอกจำเป็น
มาวาดรูป
วาดรูปสมัยจิตรกรใช่ไหมคะครูเอ๋
หนีมีรูปค่ะจิตรกรเอกจากสาวๆมีไหม
ไม่เป็นไร
คิดว่าริซ่าเหมือนดาวินชี่เหมือนแวนโก๊ะ
วาดรูปรับคุณประวีณาค่ะ
ขอบคุณที่หมอกคุณคนอิสาบอกไม่ใช่ค่ะไม่
ใช่คุณประวีณาบ่ชั้นค่ะชั้นค่ะมาทรูนะคะ
คุณลิซ่าแล้วขอโทษครับคุณลิซ่าครูเอ๋จำ
ไม่ได้เฮ็ดซ้ำผิดไงนะจำผิดนะคะต่อไปค่ะ
ข้อที่ 4 ข้อที่ 4 คนไรคะคุณเตะคุณแตฮี
มาจากโป้เกาหลีต่ายค่ะคุณเตเนี่ย
เป็น
ช่างภาพ
เป็นช่างภาพ
ถูกหรือผิดคะคุณแตฮีเป็นสร้างภาพผู้หญิง
ชอบให้ถูก
ก็ไม่รู้นะไม่รู้นะครูเอ๋
จำได้ไหมแต่ทำอะไร
ดีทำอะไรอ่ะจำได้ไหมแต่เนี่ยสูง
คิดค่ะแป๊บๆๆ
โชว์ค่าค่ะครูเอ๋เนี่ยถูกนะคะว่าผิดคู่
เอกก็เลยถูกทรายครุฑคุณแจฮีไม่ได้เป็น
ช่างภาพคุณที่ทำอะไรคะแบบคู่เอกเออนี่รีบ
เลยยังไม่ได้
คุณเตเป็น
ตำรวจค่ะเป็นตำรวจ
เป็นตำรวจ
อัดหมดแล้วคุณ jaehee นึกว่าหมดแล้วหมด
คลาสที่ถ่ายคู่เอ๋แจงไม่หมดคลาสนะคะ
เดี๋ยวขอคุยหารูปแป๊บนึงลืมเลยนะคะตอนนี้
กี่คนนะคุณลิซ่าคน Black คิดคุณโรเบิร์ต
คูณเตนะคะถ้าสาย 4 คนแล้วคนที่ 5 ถาม
เกี่ยวกับคุณสอนจรไหนคะจรอเมริกาหนอจร
เท็กซัสนะคะคุณสอน
คนนี้นะคะคุณ John  A ตอบคุณจอนแต่งงาน
แล้วนะตอนเนี้ยแต่งงานแต่แดนแต่แอนแต่
Dance แตนคุณจอนแต่งงานแล้วถูกหรือผิดคะ
ครูเอกค่ะ
พ้นไปคิดหรอคะไม่คิด
ใช่มั้ยใช่ดิแต่งงานแล้ว
ถูกมั้ย
ถูกทาง
มีลูกกี่คน
กูเย็น
[เพลง]
มีอีกพี่น้องจำได้มีลูก 3 คน
ถูกหรือผิดครูเอ๋
อกค่ะ
ชัวร์หรออาเดี๋ยวเช็คก่อนอ่ะ
ว่ามีเช็คได้เหรอคะได้ค่ะผิดละคู่เอ๋
คุณ John มีลูกกี่คนคุณ John มีลูก 2 คน
เก๋จำผิดทรายจำผิดไม่เป็นไรค่ะไม่เป็นไร
อ่ะหมดแล้วคุณ John
คนต่อไปคำถามข้อที่ 6 ค่ะใครคะคุณประวีณา
คุณประวีณารู้แล้วอุ้ยคุณประวีณาเนี่ย
เก่งจำได้ไหมนักเรียนนักเรียนนักเรียน
เนี่ยเก่งเก่งเก่งไม่เหมือนกันค่ะคุณ
ประวีณาเนี่ย
วาดรูปวาดรูปเก่งเป็นดูแล้วเนอะอย่าเพิ่ง
ตอบนะคะใจใจเย็น
คุณประวีณาวาดรูปเก่ง
ถูกหรือผิดคะครูเอ้เอ้ค่ะถุง
เร็วมากเลยอ่ะก็เมื่อกี้กูหญิงบอก
ๆ
ถูกฆ่า
คนพระเวลาวาดรูปเก่ง
เก่งมากค่ะครูอีกผู้ใหญ่เขาความจำดีตาดี
นะอุ้ยจำได้มีเกมซิกแซกเก่งไงอ่ะ
คุณประวีณาหมดแล้วค่ะ
ต่อไปใครคะคนที่ 7 นะคะคุณ
Cat  Cat  Cat  Cat
อเมริกาทรายกะคุณประวีณาเนี่ยวาดรูปเก่ง
ใช่ไหมคะนี่
คุณแชทเนี่ย
เต้นเก่งค่ะนี่ในรูปเนี้ยคนเต้นใช่ไหม
เต้นค่ะ
คุณแคทนะคะเต้นเก่ง
ถูกหรือผิดอาอาอิตัวเอกคิดว่าผิดค่ะคิด
ใช่ค่ะค่ะผิดไม่ใช่คุณแคทคิดป็น
ครูเอ๋จำได้ไหมนักเรียนคนไหนเต้นเก่ง
คุณลิซ่า
ครูค่า
วีซ่าแล้ว
แล้วคุณแคทเก่งอะไรคุณแคทหรอคุณแคะทำ
อาหารไหมไม่อุ้ยอย่าจ่ายไว้ 30 ใช่ไหมคะ
ธิชา
ท้ายคล้ายๆเต้นเวลามีคนเต้น
ก็มีอีกหนึ่งคนทำอะไร
เล่นดนตรี
ก่อนเต้นดีคนเล่นดนตรีเปียโนกีตาร์แล้วก็
มีคน
ร้องเพลง
ชายค่ะ
คุณแคทร้องเพลง
ๆ
Happy  Birthday  To  You  Happy
Birthday
คุณ
โอเคโอ้ยเอ๋รอร้องเพลงสัตว์เอ้อตกใจเหรอ
คะโอ้นี่แปลว่าหยุดห้ามร้องเพลง
อ่าใจคุณแคทร้องเพลงเก่งค่ะอะหมดแล้วคุณ
ชัดเสร็จแล้วนะคะข้อที่ 8 คุณ John
สวีเดนคุณ John สวีเดนสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะ
ยังเกี่ยวกับความเก่งนะเก่งๆโอเคค่ะ
คุณ John สวีเดนเนี่ย
นี่ค่ะว่ายน้ำว่ายน้ำเก่งนะว่ายน้ำเก่ง
ถูกหรือผิด
ถูกหรือผิดหรือถูกมากติดค่ะคิดไม่ผิดค่ะ
ใครผิดเหรอค่ะคุณ John ว่ายน้ำเก่งเหรอคะ
ให้ค่ะพิมพ์จรวยน้ำพี่จอนสวีเดนสอนสวีเดน
ว่ายน้ำเก่งคู๋จำผิดนะคะถ้าน้องไม่เป็นไร
ค่ะอ่ะต่อไปข้อที่ข้อที่เท่าไหร่แล้วก็
คือเอ๋คะติก 9 ปะ 9 ใส่ค่ะข้อที่ 9 คุณ
เคล้านะถามเกี่ยวกับคุณเค้าเป็นคนที่สิบ
ของเรา
สายค่ะไม่ไม่ไม่ถามเกี่ยวกับเก่งแล้วนะ
ห้ามอะไรคะหน้าอันนี้เนี่ยเมื่อวานนะ
เมื่อวานเองนะเอ๋คุณเคล้ามาอันนี้นะคะคน
นี้แหละคุณเคล้า
คุณเค้ามีใครคะพี่เอ๋พ่อ
แม่
เราก็คุณเค้าเนี่ยมีพี่น้อง
3 คนนะกินเขามีมีพี่มีน้อง 3 คนค่ะ
ถูกหรือผิดคะครูเอ๋ it ค่ะ
โค้งคุยเจ้านายหรอ
คุณเค้าเป็นลูกคนเดียวใช่ไหมไม่ใช่หรอคุณ
เตะคุณเซฮีคนเดียวอันนี้คนสี่คนสี่คน
ใจๆค่ะคุณเค้า
แดง 1  2  3  4 คุณเค้าเป็นรูปคนที่เท่า
ไหร่
วันที่ 4
ไม่ใช่คนที่สองคนที่สองถูกค่ะ
ไม่น่าเชื่อ
ใดๆเดี๋ยว
กูให้ดูแบบซีเรียสสีสั่งมากเลยนะคะอ่ะหมด
แล้วล่ะพรุ่งนี้เช้า
ยังค่ะใช่คุณเขาเสร็จแล้ว
คนที่ 10 คุณ
ทาดาชิค่ะอุดทาดาชินะฮะคุณทาดาชิเนี่ย
อันนี้คุณพ่อคุณแม่
คุณทาดาชิ
มีพี่น้อง 2 คน
ถูกหรือผิดคะครูค่ะ
เลยเหรอคะไม่ต้องคิดจำได้
โอคาค่ะมีที่น้อง 2 คนแล้ว
ครูเอ๋จำได้ไหมคุณทาดาชิ
เป็นรูปคนสิ่งหนึ่งหรือเป็นลูกคนโตหรือ
ว่าลูกคนเล็กคนเล็กค่ะนี่ล่ะคนทาดาชิกรรม
ได้
6 ค่า
ผิดช่องเก่งนะมีคำถามเกี่ยวกับคุณทาดาชิ
อีกไหมคะคุณทาดาชิจะเป็นหมอเกดพี่เอ๋รู้
แล้วครูเอ๋รู้แล้วใช่ไหมคะ
พูดเอ๋
มีถามเดี๋ยวขอคุยก่อนได้ไหมคะได้ค่ะ
คุณทาดาชิคุณทาดาชิ
สูง
เซนติเมตรเว็บคุณบอกผู้หญิงนะ
ทูปหรือ
ถ้าผิดทัก
ถูกค่ะ
กูข้า
จำได้จำได้
คุณทาดาชิมาจากประเทศญี่ปุ่นใช้ค่ะ
บ้านอยู่ที่ฮอกไกโด
ถูกหรือผิดจะบ้านอยู่ฮอกไกโด
อ่า
ผิดค่ะ
กินค่ะใช่ไหมคะผิดถูกค่ะครูเอ๋ถูก
บ้านมาจาก
โตเกียวใช่ไหมคะไม่ใช่เดี๋ยวโตถูกฆ่าเกีย
วโตเกียวโต
พอแล้วค่ะคุณทาดาชิ
คานาชิ by คนสุดท้ายคุณมะโกคุณโอค่ะคุณโอ
เป็นนักเรียนคนที่เท่าไหร่ของเราคะครูเอ๋
11 ค่ะเก่งมากนะคุณโอเนี่ยเกิด
แม่
คุณโอเนี่ยเกิดเดือน
มีนาคม
จำไว้ด่า
อาเดี๋ยวหนาวเดี๋ยวเดาๆ
ถูกหรือผิดเดาว่า
แต่เมื่อวานอะไรหว่านี้นะ
2 วันที่แล้วสวยเก๋ 2 วันที่แล้ว
เดือนถูกถูกถูก
ผิด
ถูกหรือผิดผิดไปถูก
ผิดค่ะผิดอ่ะครูเมย์บอกว่าผิด
ถูกค่ะเย้
ครูเอถูกนะนักเรียนซู
กูเองบอกว่าผู้หญิงถามคุณโอ๋เกิดเดือน
มีนาคม
ถูกหรือผิดเอบอกว่าผิดอ่ะ
กูอาย
จ่ายแล้วไม่คุณโอเนี่ยมึงใส่ได้เกิดเดือน
มีนาคม
คุณโอเกิดเดือนอะไร
ไม่มีอ่ะที่
9 เดือน 9 เดือน 10 เดือน 11
กันยายนตุลาคมพฤศจิกายน
พฤศจิกายนพฤศจิกา
ถ้าเดือนตุลาคม
เช็ดถ้า
เดือน 9 เดือน September นะไม่มีไอ้ห่า
กันยายนคุณโอคุณโอเกิดวันที่ 3
กันยายน
ไปกู ah จำไม่ได้ว่าเป็นที่ 10 เดือนที่
นะตัว AP แต่ว่าครูเอ๋
เหนื่อยนะคะเก่ง
ผู้หญิงเลยกูเองอ่ะเหนื่อย
อะไรดูคลิปมัน search ครูหยิกครูเอ๋
เนี่ยคิดคิดคิดจะเลยคะว่าเอ๊ย
ถูกผิดถูกผิดเหนื่อยครูหญิงอ่ะ
อยากจะหัวเราะ
ตื่นเต้นตื่นเต้น 1 หน่วย
ผู้หญิงหัวเราะครูเอ๋เหนื่อยค่ะ
กูเอกจำผิดมากๆนะคะให้กูเอลถูกมากๆอ๋อถูก
มากๆขีดนิดหน่อยเอ๋เก่งใช่ไหมค่ะก็วันนี้
ก็เป็นคลาสสุดท้ายของคอร์สสมัย b0 ไก่ค่ะ
ก็เลยมาเช็คนะคะว่าครูเอ๋เนี่ยรู้จักนัก
เรียน
จำได้ไหมจำได้โอเค lk
และ
ก็หมดเวลาแล้วนะคะค่ะให้นักเรียนฟังภาษา
ไทยเก่งๆเนาะเราฟังไปบีกินเนอร์
อินเทอร์มีเดียทแอดวานซ์จะได้ฟัง Story
ครูเอ๋ไงมอเตอร์ไซค์
รถพยาบาลปีปอบอีปอบ
เราก็นักเรียนก็จะ automatic พูดใช่มั้ย
สวัสดีก็ไม่พูดเดี๋ยวฟังมากๆพูดได้ก่อน
เขียนภาษาไทยได้นะฮะเรียนได้โอเคน้องครู
หญิงกับผู้เอกก็บ๊ายบายไปก่อนนะคะขอบคุณ
นักเรียน 11 คนชื่ออะไรบ้างครูเอ๋อ่าคุณ
Black  Peace
เมื่อวันที่สองนาทีสารพิษที่ 3 จรชู
มาร์คเกอร์วันที่ 4 คนที่สกุลทาดาชินากา
เสริฐวันที่ห้างอ่ะโคน
คุณแตฮีพักยิ้มคิม
ปิดคนนี้คุณประวีณา
Sing
คุณลิซ่าเขินคนที่ 8 คุณคุณสรคุณจอห์นโอ
Loft คนที่ 9 คนอะไรนะแฮะคุณแจ๊ด oven
คนที่ 40 คุณเคล้านะคะไปทางสกุลจำไม่ได้
เนาะพูดไม่ได้คนที่ 11 คุณโอนะครับก็เก่ง
มากติดต่อวันนี้คุณกับครูเอ๋ไปก่อนเนาะ
บ๊ายบาย
สวัสดีค่ะ
[เพลง]